you sacked Matt Ryan 23 times throughout
your career the most ever in NFL history
by the way and I wanted to do like a
little quiz I'm going to name the edge
rusher and you tell me who is the
quarterback that they sacked the most I
start with myself Phil rivers of course
Phil rivers with 16 sacks how about
Aaron Donald Russell Wilson Russell
Wilson with 16 too so we got miles
Garrett on here I'm a go Ben rburg but I
don't know he has sacked Joe Barrow nine
times Joe barl ain't even been a league
that long okay we got TJ watt I'm going
go with Joe burrow cuz it seemed like he
giving it up Baker Mayfield eight and 1
half times got JJ Watt oh I'm not going
to know this one I'm going to say pton
Andrew Luck 11 times we got my guy
Demarcus and I I know this one got to be
a man definitely Eli 14 and a half times
I I would have loved that man Eli
standing around Michael straight hand it
might be a Philadelphia Eagles
quarterback it is Donovan McNab 14 and a
half times and he had KY dmir 14 and a
half times who's the second guy